cool
taco you new canal gongadze critical
died in her hair dark emotional Nagano
nirananda
[Music]
Ozma use to monitor the Gujarati you are
the moonwalk
Tom diagram Rosangela Bonin can ha get a
choreography
yo-dee-hooo Sultanahmet Ettore Kuya the
Guru is encourage everybody coalition
traffic in Guatemala ghetto who used a
garage imatinib oh you named ray my
garage marks on the schedule
even though each cat Atoka even know who
Lisa tava you will know Calistoga
su mo no mo z tu mujer
Emilio granny oreganata no Ultimo's uno
de poder ah no tengo no you tomorrow
kitey kitey Oshima's robbery cerca de la
croix code scrutiny ah or 1300 Jeeva
Miranda Nam Iowa Nevada us cuddly koala
MOA dear mother una madre es que un
récord amigos kebab Takara Reno Nevada
presented in egt this is a brahmana so
now my god simisage cottonee Ahmad it's
a multi Allah in Arabic Arabic oh boy
Kirilenko theta hasta ahora la Fidele
oh boy tofutti yoga so akuto on quality
meals was a you are indeed Oh Kuno de
votre mère ever come back I wrote Hawaii
from committee running and wing and
holding a data room there SOE got an ID
[Music]
del Potro todo este scusi muy duro
condom or RTOG motiva multum or a bezoar
agario a tengan Otto mention the Gungan
e no Guzman autonomy Vic machine
mm Claro cometa mo ba eager ana.k type
of vets commander Abu babies before you
comin in city in Ghana coffins can look
like this they're carved into whimsical
shape and painted bright colors meant to
represent a person's life or occupation
in virgi anon city Agrabah Adhikari no
ninpo
[Music]
okay barovik a Buddha was Monique cool
evoke words Monet's a few lollies
alley-oop we any Yahoo s Manavi Nellie
anon and his family are at the center of
this extravagantly designed
larger-than-life cotton made in the
shape of whatever one desires
Papaji Kentucky in the DNA connection ID
cuff not affect morning tea a gun on it
it started about 65 years ago with an
odd request from achieved to be buried
in a coffin shaped like a cocoa pod from
there the request kept coming in an anon
father realized he had a serious
business on a pan well funerals are sad
occasion and Ghana many also see them as
an opportunity to celebrate the deceased
Papa mo no idea who yeah when I feel
tomorrow elevator analyst Manu Guney
llamo no good when an order comes in for
one of their coffins they first get the
measurements of the deceased carve the
wood into the shoes of the families
choosing create an opening and stand up
for smoothness it then goes to an artist
for painting once interior stuffed it's
ready to be delivered to the family and
these coffins are not only delivered
locally and Los Angeles
maganda copy Jimmy democracia as Fernan
he already has his picked out this
morning I can move we were to swing
somewhat anyway covers are very sharp
when the rock won the WWE Championship
in 2013 he wanted a custom belt this
video is about the guy who made that
belt this is Dave Milliken the industry
leader in championship belt making
there's also a huge wrestling fan yep
that sounds about right
he's doing the business for a while
since he was a little kid I was 13 when
I made my first belt a it was really bad
the guy who made belts before David was
this guy Reggie Parkes taking me under
his wing had everything to do with my
development even my initial respect in
this business with veterans
everybody knew Reggie Parkes nobody knew
Dave Mulliken and here's how they're
made step 1 artwork step 2 h8 step 3
would be the bolt work step 4
plating and then from there you pretty
much have a complete belt
although some have paint some don't have
paint it varies from design to design
each belt is unique in its own way I've
actually been asked how many belts I've
made by now we're or in the thousands
believe it or not the WWE is that you
biggest client right now
somebody doors just as many belts as lip
sync battle television but we're here
for wrestling nostalgia countless stars
ranging from stone coal to John Cena
himself have worn Dave's belts it's
certainly a labor of love as some of
these both can take up to a year to
finish which begs the question which one
is his favorite asking me la favorite
belts like asking a to take my favorite
kid that would be a lot of kids to have
to choose from
I have one job making the best clothing
in the world my name is Martin
Greenfield I used to be maximilien
Grunfeld
when I was born but I changed it to make
American because I loved this country my
craft is very difficult to define
because it's many things I am a maker of
clothing I know how to measure I know
how to fit people very few people could
match me I was responsible for all the
battle Clinton I measured in the White
House Obama measured in the White House
so then I made of bone fractures we
never had to fix nothing my life is a
sad life before I came to America
because I lost my family I was left
alone everybody was dead we were
occupied
ouch which was a month later I was in
the concentration camp a year in two
months it was my second day in Auschwitz
there's no more names a consideration
can only numbers when they called me
they sent me to devil the head they ever
spoke my language
he was choose they asked me are you a
tailor no I said if you push only had to
make the color
he says I'll make you account so we have
make God the pain is still a my heart
about my family I still dream about my
family like they're alive but on the
outside you will never know
I didn't think I was going to survive I
was liberated by eyes now General
Eisenhower came in when I was fifteen
and a half years old
and when they walked in I shook his hand
trying to save my life
I came to America September 18 1947 they
gave me the job as a tailor I told my
boss listen
Eisenhower liberate I want you to make
him a three-piece suit like I wear
myself he liked it once he had the first
three-piece suit from then on you didn't
see Eisenhower and loaded with
three-piece suits so that's how it
started I made sure we dressed all the
presidents with Obama first he wanted me
to copy a suit I don't copy anybody
everybody copies my suit so if he wants
me to make something I have to measure
next day sensor name it would be a
pleasure to meet you there I'm happy
when I'm at the factory my job is the
most important thing in my life quality
is so important to me because I know
that's what kept me in business and
that's why I'm here talking to you
[Music]
you
[Music]
yeah every guitar has a story my name is
Rick Kelly I custom make guitars here at
carmine street guitar I make guitars
from reclaimed lumber old New York City
building wood from two hundred year old
trees most of the wood is being thrown
away so I just dumpster dive for it the
craft of it is is one of my favorite
things dental building from the
materials that are historic and coming
up with instruments that make music and
kind of alive in a different way a lot
of you know steps involved I bring the
wood here man then I have to Dean a lit
and then surface it and cut it to shape
on the bandsaw stand it smooth and then
I use a mostly shellac finishes which is
a natural finish a lot of people have
come through carmine street guitars and
bought my custom guitars over the years
Bob Dylan Lou Reed how do you Smith and
Roger Waters Steely Dan band so many
other bands to be able to give life back
into the instrument from the old Timbers
that built this city is a wonderful
feeling to be able to make it have a new
light and turn into something that makes
music it's wonderful
[Applause]